yeah okay here we go here we go double
the points double the points oh my
goodness I have to disable my right
mouse click oh it's gonna happen at a
very bad time I could feel it
at a very bad time this night is gonna
be a monster isn't he
it's gonna be a monster I could have
taken that keep that out of there
oh okay which one is gonna be taken I
think this is still good somehow put
pressure on that bishop double rooks hmm
it's really gonna be taken I don't want
to move this that it kink closer but a
post up here maybe or maybe get a pot
all the way up here control f6 I think
the bishop
my knight is loose from this square so
there might be some tricky Knight move
okay not really the direction I wanted
to go ahead okay I don't want to do okay
maybe I do want to do this now
and now I have to be careful of a fork
if this King wasn't there there'd be
some tricky stuff I want to get to this
square even I could get this pawn and
then this pond
alright this rook pressure on the knight
take that pawn got my other rook working
take the knight take the bishop maybe
the guy will smile slip that I should
have given check right away
don't take pin pieces attack them no
stay on me
no Stanley just keep marching does that
mean this is me
that's me back determine what a tough
game to start okay here we go here we go
oh let's try to sneak in an h2 I have to
disable my my my route my man
tongue-tied it's happening again
tongue-tied syndrome watch over B 5 H -
H - oh my goodness
h2 is on hang on h2 just like that don't
blink don't blink h2 strikes again
everybody's favorite square on the
chessboard age - fear that square pair
me up I go for some cheap tricks try and
score points this guy is 16 slow down
whoa slow down ok
b4 don't spy test here no matter what
advanced care oh oh my goodness I have
to baby step g4 yes what a wonderful way
to lose a tempo everybody's favorite way
to lose a tempo whoa there go the light
squares there they go they're gone just
like that
gone are the light squares and now my
light square Bishop is gonna turn out to
be the big bad wolf the big bad wolf
oh I didn't wanna have to do that stop
the knife from trickiness take this
night I like my dark square bishop I
need him around here now
I keep checks over here I should really
think about developing Queen back low
pins pins pins pins
it was defended I need to complete my
development these pawns are Swiss cheese
over here look at them they're split
eyes really do this I want to be able to
take with the pawn I think what's that
rook up to mm-hmm oh my goodness what am
i doing 16 seconds I'm at time open this
position up my rook is on this file for
a reason attack that King Oh
oh my goodness take this pond oh that
can't be right I'm getting a rook
they're getting a bishop I shouldn't
take of their Knight first Oh take this
pawn here this is a pot in this pawn is
pinned I'm hitting the knight take here
I should have been open this position up
so much sooner
so much sooner okay I think this is good
that Knight is counting a crossfire
tricky stuff six seconds no way take
this Knight I gotta move quick here no
matter what
I'm gaining out of time oh that's double
check here no matter what I just have to
move time burners time burners where
they at down on time oh my goodness my
heart is racing twenty four twenty
nineteen sixteen twelve twenty five
minutes remaining
oh okay twelve points there's a lot who
have I think double or more can I get
another one I'm not gonna always play
its opening and I no no I have to get a
couple wins though for this one gonna
happen again
no g3 says no no no no no but maybe
there's a way to bite at that point and
that's what I'm looking for bite at that
pond right he
fight at this pond take and then play in
the H file somehow get my net on c4 it's
a very sensitive point on the white side
I'm looking to go there with tempo now
hitting the Queen in the bishop take the
pawn if pin I play d6 and then once
again this move is renewed doubled pawns
I'm okay with these Knights are boxed
out with pawns doubled on the of this
file here the e-file b5 and e6
my opponent isn't moving bring my bishop
out let's take care first dark square
bishop oh I could do this too want to
keep the night away maybe I can take
this pawn first my queen is pinned my
knight is pinned
you're not even move my knight I want to
chew this night away give a bishop
bishop check and then night here let's
do this right away my opponent's way
down on time way down at time and now
attack the pinned piece the knight is
pinned big trouble could do not here as
well
Hahn takes Knight they don't have any
time back to tournament 20 30 30 29 24
20 madden is up there Assad John Madden
he flies
John Madden flies Queens gambit okay
gain some space and reinforce this this
nights gonna camp out here I think I
want to just take him right away and
then weasel my Bishop around to h4 this
is what I was talking about my diary
Bishop is stupid so he's gonna get
working hopefully and soon hopefully and
school at c5 is a good square and c5 I
hit the bishop bishop h4 should have
been doing that first the queen is quite
short on squares is she not I can't be
good
queen is tied down
I have a uh I have Forks how many Forks
do you want I shouldn't take my rock
he's passed post up on this square
double Brooks if the Queen moves I'm
pushing that pond pretty much no matter
what pretty much no matter what ponds
pinned hit three times now if the rook
moves I'll do this first and then
capture on this square let's take on
push on a clean check I'd pin oh there's
no good solution here cleanness pretty
much stuck it's gonna be me made is not
long off I have resign resign time 21
minutes pieces pinned
she's attack it good well sir throw my
knight in there okay they resigned back
to tournament 38 36 30 29 28 24 21
minutes remaining knio knio hang on so
far oh is this gonna happen maybe okay
when Tony structure my Knights getting
chased around a little bit let's just
take here do that no matter what trades
I'm okay with hang on oh I shouldn't
take off my knight maybe I was really do
this I would have dropped my knight here
I want to get to this square dark square
Bishop get these this pawn going my
queen is here did too um get this
rolling pawn push I think I might need
to take I don't want the night sitting
on that square Knight right here
take with my rook because my queen needs
to defend my knight can maybe even throw
this in between move in Queen is hit I
have this square available and maybe get
a fork take with the Queen of an outpost
shrinky Knight double up on that pond
and attack the pinned piece he's pinned
my knight is supported well enough and
this pond could be challenged so he
might just be taken might be in top
intolerable
past pond maybe I should have given a
check so the Queen couldn't black hate I
think I just march on keep pushing this
past pond it might clean more active
this prawn could drop but I think
activity for my clean right here seems
good pinning the night like here just
keep pushing right here get that rook
well King here I give check and I think
there's close to mate now somehow
there's mate not long enough I think I
where's the main well for a second I
thought I was gonna drop my queen oh
that's what check that's me
finally back to tournament I probably
missed a bunch of mates there fifty five
fifty to fifty forty to less than twenty
did I play this guy earlier less than
twenty I wasn't doubling the points was
this the one that I baby stepped G for I
think it might have been and then I got
at those those light squares Knight f4
and now h4 h5 is the plan if this pawn
moves light square issues stopping that
aren't thing really well why did I take
their let's do this if I can't do this
now I can't Castle queenside now okay
gotta get developed Queen trait notes
defend this pawn first let's do it like
this I want to keep this square under
control both the Knights could make use
of it if I captured my bishops there to
defend my rook after there's a capture
on g4 I want to restrict these Knights I
want my knight on f4 as well King up to
g3 looks good the knight might hop into
this square I think this is a decent
home for my king it's contest' this file
it's likely to open this pawn isn't
around I have this type of pawn break oh
this is close to maybe being
maybe not crack at this structure if he
moves I get this in somehow maybe not
time situation maybe I should do this
pawn push come over on this side of the
board capture towards the center I need
to reinforce this point it's gonna be
trouble
take it might I get my knight over here
I don't even know how to assess this
position sixteen seconds what's gonna
come off
what does that night move you've been
doing no you don't know what you're
doing yeah I think I don't think ain't
getting up and getting active my bishop
needs to do something else that's for
sure
uh I should just take him that pond or
that night what kind of pieces hit there
we go oh that was a cool pre move to do
who would have thought who would have
thought I was actually gonna capture
their back to tournament 71-68 64-56
tight pack up here chess Oh vision
double up those points nearly halfway
there
nearly halfway oh this might be quick
win chess evasion mine is to double the
points and give me the give me the win
right back to tournament first just like
that eight out of eight I think mm-hmm
sixteen sixteen minutes 50 seconds okay
let's go with this a more aggressive
version of the bad Vanek system h3 g4
and I have this under control
let's go with that for maybe f5 Queen d2
Bishop h6 double on the F file I like my
bishop too much stops Queen b6 tough to
I don't know how great it would have
been lay here would just drop a pawn
rook F - this is dropping upon no no no
no Knight takes they take with the pawn
my queen is defending the bishop
what more is there to post up here
whenever I want I don't want to do just
yet just double rooks I could have
pushed and got in the rook this seems
good as well though double those rooks
and what is the knight going to do okay
the knight is kind of stuck can I get a
knight on this square how can you get
there okay I open this up my queen gonna
be trapped she's not gonna be trapped is
she want to open up the h-file
can't take like this I have pressure on
f8 so look this is me McQueen was there
if the other capture came I was gonna
play rook f4 to h4 or at least try
ninety eighty six eighty two sixty nine
sixty four
all right fifteen halfway point in the
tournament okay there's just um I have
too much success with this opening
potentially quick wins and it's also
kind of solid h2 not so fast
each to f3 h3 now maybe above I get a
deck I get a Bishop and then a rogue and
even more than that if rook takes I get
this Knight and then there's a deadly
pin oh the whole farm fell right there
that was the whole farm just like that
dark square bishop once he went game
over right light squares to bishops on
that diagonal are gonna be brutal you're
gonna be brutal get the Queen here
probably no matter what this is this is
this is big trouble
this is matin minion how many let's just
attack this pawn how do I need the
castle this is a big trouble now
I could have taken that night by the way
you could have gone this is me these
bishops are deadly and adjacent
diagonals 110 86-82 69 course I was up a
bunch of material now and so that helped
but bishops on adjacent diagonals they
are tough guys remember that my
opponents trying to fishing call me no
don't you dare don't you dare
let's grab some space I also vacate this
square for my knight and now let's get
in b4 even if I am sacking upon hang on
let's watch over this first I've
weakened d3 now it's not a sack when I
get B
four and I want to open up the B file I
queen after this I'm anticipating the D
file opening up pawn push maybe I just
jump in here let's keep this I have a
support point on c5 this pawn goes
anywhere okay that's just me winning
upon now and I can keep my structure as
is I've opened up the diagonal as well
this I can't take let's do that and I
want to kick this night away
oh not moving fast and I should have to
be a bit cautious here this h-file is
dangerous very dangerous too dangerous I
got a move this is way too dangerous
oh I'm on this watch out for made on
each - I'm gonna scream I'll scream if I
get made on each - never let that happen
oh my goodness that was check that was
check take this ten seconds take with
the king so the Queen's would come off
please no
Oh oh this is bad news this is bad news
six seconds no no no no no no no oh my
goodness we're gonna take that I got a
block here I got a I got a move very
fast
oh my goodness I want to tell him point
eight seconds 130 126 107
oh man that tricky cookie was so tricky
oh my goodness it's not just the Knights
who have their fun of being tricky okay
Wow Wow
that h-file is so dangerous it's so
dangerous isn't it you have to believe
me I just watch just watch and you'll
see how dangerous it is
give me the dark square Bishop keep the
knight out of here this structure
cancels out the bishop in the night if
pawn push now I could do this mm-hmm
maybe trap the bishop as well let's get
rid of him he's a bit tricky maybe I'd
do this
yeah the bishops cooked no
Bishop here b5 and I don't I don't have
to capture him right away
clear my throat sorry about that pawn
push might have been available actually
counter-attacking in and doing something
else
take this pawn take that take on h3 and
I'm on the rook and then kind of my
opponent isn't moving
ten minutes remain in the tournament on
the rook and then I think no matter what
I just kind of come to a safe square
potential pins
my queen on this diagonal you're gonna
open up the H file that Knight is kind
of stuck isn't he
let's check where is the mate they're
down on time back to term at 150 146 108
107 10 minutes remaining 10 minutes
remaining
whew John Madden T 9 16 T 9
I'm sure T Knight knows all about the
fishing poles of course I'm not playing
as the black side here am i and can I
really maintain that all right we're
gonna try and get in the center its d4
all right I have my center supported and
let's do this if there's a check I might
just move my king yeah I want to keep
pieces on the board looks crazy I'm
gonna do it though I want to stop Knight
f5 and open the square for my King this
Bishop is close to being trapped and he
is trapped no he's not
the knight moved that square is
available okay let's do this I don't
want the Queen to have this here and
that my king is a fighter apparently
he's a big fighter and now this pawn
wants to shoo the night away
he's out of here he's got a run home I
think I keep marching in okay this might
be taken this is wild this is a wild
position look at that pond oh okay okay
this is quite dangerous Oh
especially when there's a knight fork oh
boy oh boy it's looking pretty dangerous
here it's looking pretty oh I could move
my knight right here my goodness
let's do that let's do that I should
have done that sooner these prawns are
gonna be monsters gonna be monsters very
soon
oh now they're not let's defend that
pawn this pawn isn't going anywhere
gonna be a check I take this pawn next
no tricky Forks that's me whoa that's a
cool mate that Knight took away that
flight square 170 166 127 if John Madden
and I get paired up that's going to be a
big big game eight minutes remain eight
minutes remain I'm gonna give up I'm
okay with double pawns
came the night I'm threatening this pawn
now and just to mess up the structure as
well so now this night has gone just
like that
he's gone so discovered tricks push my
pawn let's do this
get my knight into G for an extra piece
to now work with it's gonna go there
anyhow
if pawn push I don't have to react no
need to react and keep my finish up
right here to watch over this square
could also blend a fork here and I don't
have to move this night if he's attacked
with h3 because I have mating ideas
mating ideas keep my queen on this
diagonal Bishop here adjacent diagonals
on push I still stay on this dog and
I'll play back to a7 it's gonna be taken
should I even Castle really don't need
to okay we might end up seeing this
happen and it discovered to double check
me and that's what we're going to have
that's mate back to tournament 190 186
147 138 less than seven minutes
remaining Patriot chess before and whoa
okay this is gonna get wild it's gonna
get wild isn't it I gotta watch out for
tricks over here how are they gonna
castle with my bishop on c4 bishop but
how they're going Queen side okay keep
their night out of this square I think I
want to preserve my my dark square
bishop for sure let me kick that guy out
of there I don't know I don't know okay
to be careful for sure back up can move
my knight I think this actually works
take like that and then I'll take with
the pawn
I like my knight right where
is closer to the center and I'm not sure
where I want to go with my bishop let's
do this opposite colored bishop pending
apparently so this extra pawn that I
have is not really doing a whole lot is
he okay I think I could have I just
dropped my pawn right here could get
this pawn back though let's defend them
okay I think I could kick this rook off
of this file see if I can win this
endgame it spawns on dark squares I want
to keep them on dark squares so I have
potential targets get this pawn up a
little bit discovered tricks comes with
check
okay now this pawn is gonna follow and I
might just actually get oh he's not
gonna be trapped I thought for a second
he would be trapped but he's now let's
do this get this pawn up a little bit
more now I can I shouldn't have done
this
okay my king is gonna head over the
other direction other direction to tack
these puns get my King on b6 and get my
pawn up to b5 is the plan Connor tacking
I cabbed that available they're down on
time back to tournament 210 206 168 I
have to keep winning are we gonna get
paired up myself and John Madden
I forget who won the last time we played
last time we were paired up
and I can't pair it up it might hit me
with an air and then and then what after
the air I'll get some points hopefully
oh yeah 210 206 which john madden doing
is he winning let's see john madden this
is john man's game nothing here in my
game come on white come on white why
looks pretty good maybe no they're down
bishop that hurts nothing in my game oh
man he's down five seconds come on white
bishop is watching overage - Bishop
takes Bishop takes age - age - age -
again nothing in my game Oh
each - was right there oh oh there's a
pin okay Aaron my game give me points
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
leaders oh I think I got some points I
have to check after this one I'm pretty
sure I got some points for that I'm
pretty sure he got some points okay I
want to focus on e5 it's weakened my
knight would love to be there one day
and I'm on this pawn
twice do I really want to take it maybe
not actually yeah I'll do it
no no I won't start the guard this I was
gonna play this right away build up my
Center get this pawn in advance and
break down this so much for that my
knight needs to go somewhere else now
let's take care pawn takes I take care
Knight takes after watch over this now I
could take here it's much different if
the knight moves the Queen's are in
tension with one another I'm also on
this pawn my knight working my pawns
advancing open up both of these files
from my rooks pawn push here and now I'm
actually getting material up a rook and
then just advanced just take this Knight
out if he plays here right f4 I'll just
take them and push
who cares about the night the never
resign cut that King off King position
guard my rook and then advance my pawns
let's grab this one first
throw in a check let's come over here
advance these pawns me 1 2 3
what's that mate that's me to 40 to 20
no no no no - to 4226
he won that game 136 136 136 you gotta
win this game I think if I win this game
I'll get it
Bishop g7 I had I'd have to win this
game in how many seconds in order to be
assured that I could I could get it I
want to get rid of my LightSquared
Bishop good versus bad Bishop type of
position plan this get in b5 over here
this pawn advance going there gonna go
g4 let's stop it if it is played let's
get this advancing both my rooks working
this pawn is weak my to open it up a
little bit still want to pile up on that
and then my bishop could drop back to
this square triple up Queen here I'm on
this pond as well I don't know if I want
to take it I think I have enough Drive
enough oh they already called it second
place oh man they called that too early
didn't a that was that was a fairy oh
wait a second even if I got it
oh well that's why they called it even
if I woulda won that game 20 points out
that would have been enough ah man good
games all excellent tournament by mr.
Madden there 18 out of eighteen to sixty
six to forty 188 176 ah man knocked the
wind right out of my sails